frank wright colts coach who was the
eagles offensive coordinator in 2017
when they won the super bowl carson
wentz was injured in december that year
at the rams torn acl nick foles came in
and got it done
frank wright getting the chance to get
carson wentz inherit the contract
got gm cult uh colts gm chris ballard on
board with it
and you know this is what's fascinating
because reich is caught between doug
peterson the former coach of the eagles
and wentz something went wrong with that
relationship right clearly right
something dysfunctional caused those two
guys to fall apart and manifested itself
in wence
being awful last year frank wright
believes it's not about wentz
frank wright believes wentz isn't broken
he said yesterday i cringe when i hear
stuff about carson wentz being broken
chris th this to me is is a fascinating
experiment
yeah because will we see the whence that
we saw 17 18 19
or will we see the guy that we saw in
2020 yeah we're going to find out fairly
quickly they got the seahawks coming to
town to start the season no i mean
in a lot of ways i i mean it i feel like
it's
it's a little bit like the ryan
tannehill story to a degree
i mean just in the fact that i like i
think you know revisionist history a
little is like you know it's all about
last year and we look at it and yes last
year wasn't good
and he did some stupid things and they
weren't good as a team there's no doubt
about it
but i do feel like yeah like you're kind
of saying the three years before that
are kind of being lost in the shuffle
and one of those years being like mvp
caliber football
to where you can't forget about either
so you know i i think we're
we're we're seeing a story why i say
tana hill it's just he's going to a
place
where the offense is going to fit him
yeah he's getting a second chance but
what's even greater than the tannehill
thing is like what you said mike there's
a real relationship here
there's a guy that was part of the
process
in drafting carson wentz i mean i've i
had conversations about frank wright i
mean
about carson wentz with frank wright you
know his rookie year and things like
that
you know i think the way he talked about
him he looks at him as a special player
you know big moves well good arm i mean
he's got everything you want
as far as physically to be the franchise
be the man that guy that dude type of
quarterback
and now maybe with the colts and that
culture there and frank wright kind of
leading him down the way
maybe that bridges the gap too between
the locker room and carson wentz where
there's not
like his strength obviously that was an
issue in philadelphia
so i'm with you mike it's going to be an
interesting experiment but one where i
just feel
i think i'm going to be shocked if it
doesn't work i think more than the other
way around
it was early 2019 after the eagles had
to make a choice between
wentz and nick foles and it was never
much of a choice they were sticking with
the guy
that they had traded up to get the guy
that they had decided to pay the guy
that they were going to build their team
around
foles left via free agency to
jacksonville
and the story started to come up about
wence as
a guy that yeah maybe a little aloof a
little standoffish
not not the kind of personality that you
need to pull the team together and and
he actually legitimized those reports by
saying yeah i need to get better
and and you continue to hear just little
flashes of that
that this may partially be wence now
maybe reich
knows how to draw you know the better
aspects of his personality and there are
certain people who will have that effect
definitely you know we all have mixed
aspects of our personality we've got an
inclination
to be good we've got an inclination to
be difficult and the people you're
around will either draw out one or the
other and maybe reich knows how to draw
out good carson wentz and maybe it's
once reich
left after they won that super bowl to
cap the 2017
season after josh mcdaniels jilted the
colts and the colts are looking around
who the hell is our coach going to be
and frank wreck's gone maybe not having
reich in philadelphia
maybe that's one of the ingredients in
whence not having someone there who
would speak to
and attract his better angels well i
think there is
you know a true human connection there
between their faith right we know carson
went like
carson went very you know very into the
christian religion and
and frank reich's the same way so i do
think there's a common bond with that
to your point mike i think that is real
uh and and i think it is real as far as
you know the other things you're talking
about too being able to draw the human
out a little bit
to be better that way you know well
whatever that is
you know carson wentz i think was one of
those guys who kind of took the approach
of like hey i'm the quarterback and i'm
going to be the quarterback and
you know not worry about everything else
and just focus on my job
and guys will respect me that way yeah
that's cool
but when you are that guy and you kind
of like you know hey you're friends with
people in the locker room but you never
really let anybody in and like
make them feel a part of it you you put
yourself into like
you got to win then you got to if you're
going to be that guy because when you
don't do well and things go bad people
are going to look at you like well
he kind of holds himself off as like a
little different than the rest of us
or he's his own guy and that's not
always going to gain you the benefit of
the doubt in the locker room so
hopefully frank wright can like preach
that to him
and carson wentz hopefully he can just
take some pressure off of
himself to realize damn this is a good
team you're on
i mean really good maybe better offense
than you were on that super bowl team
that year
so you don't need to do it all and once
is one of those guys mike too he's got
like
you know he's got enough inc ability
individually to at
when things aren't good to kind of be
stupid and careless because he's like
man i'm good i'm a great athlete i've
always gotten away i'll make a play i'll
do
something and as we know that just
doesn't work in the nfl to live that way
so hopefully he can rein him in on all
those aspects
and he can get back to being the great
player he was two years ago
receiver t.y hilton who was drafted by
the colts the same year the colts
acquired andrew luck became a free agent
earlier this year
eventually resigned in indianapolis he's
excited
about carson wentz for one specific
reason let's hear from hilton
i caught with him before so you know go
take take
maybe a little bit but um i think we'll
be fine once we once we get the thorn
once we understand each other
um like the one thought session we had
was was pretty pretty good it was on the
money he has a big arm you know and he
he likes to throw it so you know it's
exciting it's fun so
you know it's gonna be it's gonna be
special and we know you like to go deep
down the field we haven't seen that as
much the last couple years do you feel
like there'll be an added emphasis in
that
uh we can't get away too much but uh
it's gonna be fun
hey you know you got to have somebody
who can get the football down the field
if you want to make an offense go
because you got to have that threat
chris as you said when we realized what
patrick mahomes is going to be
he forces a defense to cover
every square inch every blade of grass
when you have a guy that's got the arm
to do that the defense has more
pressure on it because it's got to worry
about what's behind it
in addition to what's in front of it
yeah that's right and this guy's a he's
a big
aggressive down the field thrower that's
where he
you know made made his his move as an
mvp type player back in 2017 and all
that
you know that's another thing that's you
know was a disservice with the
philadelphia eagles
you got a quarterback who can stand in
the pocket and buy time
and make big time plays down the field
and they didn't have a damn guy to beat
anybody down the field
so that's where it's going to be
different and their system at time
lended it to
hey wait you're a big guy with an
explosive arm but we're gonna jam in
four yard completions all the time too
so that didn't really do anything to
like accentuate his talents either
and that's where i think it it could all
work out here
with the colts and if you asked and i
think we talked about this at the end of
last year
the colts one of their big issues with
their team last year towards the end
especially
was what t.y hilton was talking about it
was philip rivers and no disrespect but
we know his arm wasn't exactly
you know jump popping off the radar gun
at this point of his career
to where teams yeah they weren't worried
about anything really deeper than 25 30
yards down the field with phillip rivers
now to your point it's going to change
the dynamic of the offense and make
jonathan taylor more
dangerous and all the other little
gadget plays frank reich has underneath
more dangerous because of once his big
arm
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports